BECAUSE THERE’S NO UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS THAT AMERICAN CITIZENS
MAY BE REACTING AGAINST.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE, EXACTLY.
HERE TO TELL US, A MAN WHOSE
NAME HAS BECOME A SYNONYM FOR
RECKLESSNESS, BUT HE WAS LEARNED
FROM HIS EXPERIENCES AND HAS
SOME INTERESTING THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT THE MOMENT WE ARE IN RIGHT
NOW.
JORDAN BELFORD, THE ORIGINAL
BOTH OF WALL STREET.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM ON
TONIGHT.
YOU HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THIS
FROM EVERY POSSIBLE ANGLE,
YOU’VE WATCHED IT FOR DECADES,
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON
HERE?
>> WELCOME I THINK YOU HAD IT
RIGHT ON THE HEAD.
AND THAT WAS MY THESIS FOR
TONIGHT.
THIS WAS REALLY A CONVERGENCE OF
A FEW DIFFERENT THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, FINALLY THE LITTLE
GUY HAS THE ABILITY TO FIGHT
BACK THROUGH A CONVERGENCE OF
TECHNOLOGY, THE PLATFORMS FOR
TRADING, THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE AS A GROUP.
SO IN THE PAST, YOU COULD’VE
NEVER DONE THIS BEFORE.
SO THERE ARE TWO TYPES IN THIS
WORLD.
THERE IS LEGITIMATE ONCE THAT’S
A NATURAL PART OF THE MARKET AND
ANOTHER PART THAT ARE THE HEDGE
FUNDS THAT GANG UP AND LITERALLY
WILL SHORT A STOCK ALMOST DOWN
TO ZERO.
THEY TRIED TO SPREAD NEGATIVE
NEWS, INVESTIGATIONS, AND THAT’S
WHAT IS SEEN WITH GAME STOP.
THIS, I THINK, CONNECTS TO A FAR
BIGGER THING THAN JUST TRYING TO
MAKE A FEW BUCKS ON A TRADE.
THIS IS ABOUT THE END OF THE
MOVIE OF THE BIG SHORT -- ALL
THE BAD GUYS WENT TO JAIL.
JUST KIDDING.
NOBODY WENT TO JAIL.
I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS THERE’S
SOMETHING WRONG IN THE PIT OF
THEIR STOMACH.
YOU CAN SILENCE PEOPLE, YOU CAN
DO PLATFORM PEOPLE AND GET AWAY
WITH IT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS -- REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT -- SOMETHING IS WRONG.
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISLE UNITED ON
THIS ONE THING, YOU NOTED THAT.
BOTH SIDES UNITE IT BECAUSE IT
WAS MONEY SORT OF TAKES THE
POLITICS OUT OF IT.
SO WHAT HAPPENS HERE IS THESE
PEOPLE -- IF YOU ACTUALLY DIG
INTO THE BOARDS, I THINK MY
FIRST REACTION WAS OH, THERE’S A
PUMP AND DUMP.
BUT THAT’S REALLY NOT WHAT IS
GOING ON.
IF YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
MESSAGES, THEY ARE MAD, THEY
WANT TO PROVE SOMETHING, IT’S
NOT NECESSARILY ABOUT MONEY.
BUT THEY ARE ANGRY AS.
THEY HAVE SOME NOMINATION TO GET
BACK.
AND BADLY FOR THE STOCKS.
I HOPE PEOPLE DON’T LOSE MONEY
IN THE PROCESS.
>> I WONDER, NOW THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED, EVERYBODY KNOWS IT HAS
HAPPENED, AND THE HEDGE FUNDS
AND WALL STREET STUFF IS MORE
VULNERABLE THAN ANYBODY IMAGINED
AND THE INTERNET STILL EXIST.
WHAT IS THIS GOING FORWARD?
WE CAN’T CONTINUE AS WE HAVE,
CAN WE?
>> SURE.
ONE THING WALL STREET AND THE
HEDGE FUNDS ARE REALLY GOOD AT
IS CLOSING GAPS AND FINDING
THESE INEFFICIENCIES AND CLOSING
THEM UP.
SO WHAT THESE PEOPLE ON
REDDIT -- HATS OFF TO THEM BY
THE WAY.
IT’S BRILLIANT WHAT THEY DID.
THEY FOUND A REAL INEFFICIENCY
IN THE MARKET AND A GAP WHERE
SOMETHING HAD BEEN DRAMATICALLY
OVER SHORTED AND THEY COULD
ACTUALLY GET ENOUGH BUYING
POWER.
WALL STREET NOW KNOWS THAT.
SO I WOULD BE VERY SHOCKED IF
HEDGE FUNDS WOULD CREATE ANOTHER
SITUATION SO QUICKLY WHERE IT
WAS SO OVERLY SHORTED THAT IT
WOULD BE THAT EASY FOR PEOPLE TO
COME IN AS A GROUP AND BRING THE
STOCK BACK UP.
SO THAT MIGHT -- BUT I BELIEVE
THIS IS A PARADIGM SHIFT RIGHT
NOW.
THE LITTLE GUY FINALLY IS
EQUIPPED, INFORMATION TRAVELS
INSTANTLY.
IT USED TO ONLY BE THE BIG GUYS.
YOU SEE ALL THIS STUFF HAPPEN
BEFORE THE LITTLE GUY, THE BIG
GUYS POLLUTING AND DOING THE
STUFF, SO NOW THE LITTLE GUY
FINALLY HAS THE ABILITY TO
DISPLAY THAT SAME GAME.
AT LEAST SOMEWHAT.
AND THERE IS GOING TO BE A
RADICAL CHANGE, IT’S NOT GOING
TO BE THE SAME.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU’VE HAD A
WILD PERSONAL LIFE.
THAT WAS SO MUCH MORE
INTERESTING AND INSIGHTFUL THAN
ANYTHING I’VE HEARD ON ANY OTHER
CHANNEL ON WHAT WE ARE SEEING